they had a female guest on there and she
was talking about like women
asking for gifts and stuff before they
give up the
so i guess he saw something we haven't
spoken
since but i guess he saw something i
said and he started posting clips from
that
like digging up their podcast which was
shady and then
also uh trying to allude to the fact
that i asked them for gifts before i
gave up any
which was totally false that's not what
happened so yeah asking for no gifts at
all
so look for it
not for a goddamn thing and let me let
me let it be clear i don't clean your
car wash your car
nothing i don't first of all first of
all i don't ask you could be up
a billion i ain't asking you for sh if
you want to give it to me all right
that's one
minute but you not on the first date i
had to give my daughter something to eat
before he took me out so i was like can
you run me by the mcdonald's real quick
because i'm running behind woo
we get to mcdonald's all she got was her
classic a milkshake
four piece nugget and a small fry when
the when the lady at the window asked
for the bridge
he's like where is that yeah you said
run me through
and i even asked him did he want
anything but look it was at that moment
that i knew
you were never getting this because he
ain't pay for your daughter food
what
sorry she said i don't ask [ __ ] see if
you want to get it from cool
i was about to get through that and you
know what she's right she doesn't ask
people for for ish she doesn't
she expects and that makes it worse
it's your first date and i'm paying for
your daughter's happy meal
first date and i'm paying
for your daughter's happy meal yeah
yeah it doesn't say anything about the
guy says more about you
but whatever
on what planet are we taking your
daughter out to eat on a first date
i can understand 10 dates in 15 dates in
the first date before the date even
starts i'm running late
i don't even can you run me and my
daughter in your car so we get some food
and you expect me to pay on the that
already tells me that you're going in
with zero expectations like you
you you think i'm a simpson yellow skin
simpsons
on the first date oh like that famous
character from
the uh the the cartoon character
you were rough you were simpson bruh
bruh imagine if i show up on the first
date rip my pants off like yo let's get
this
that's what it's like you brought your
daughter in my car on the first date
that's not a problem to bring your
daughter in the car that's not what the
problem is
i mean and it's not even the fact that
she's asking
asking for [ __ ] doesn't make you a gold
digger or not
you're expecting though i disagree he
had to
just do it not even ask you would you
wouldn't
you you don't have to ask you would just
have to do it
no no even asking for a ride on a first
date for you and your daughter's a
problem
ruff we're going to get to know each
other for the first time
you're bringing your daughter in front
of me how are you responsible do you
have to be
see what you're saying listen if i go on
a date with single mom that's not an
issue my problem is
i'm going to take my time before i get
to know the child if we're going to get
to that point
i'm not going to introduce myself to the
child on some willy-nilly type thing
and it also tells me that you don't have
your [ __ ] together where you can't
manage
both having a child and having a
relationship life we're on the
first date this is the one where you you
come in with the best
your best foot forward well maybe that
was the best with forward
that's the problem um you know what i'm
saying i see absolutely what you're
saying
bro i've seen a lot of [ __ ] on first
date i never seen that
yo give me a ride for me my daughter
that's weird
right after jump tell me about
mcdonald's i can get her a meal because
she's not been fed yet
that's another level are you not paying
for this meal that i'm just
first date you're not paying for my
daughter's meal
you're not getting then you're you're
trash
and you're not worthy enough well uh you
know what bro it's okay he you dodged me
no he died he died
he dodged one let me chill that's what
it is
and sometimes whenever you take a l like
that it's really just a win
because you dodged one my guy that's
that's what i'm saying
i see what you i see where you're from
absolutely
it was crazy it's not she would have
realized the mistake afterwards but you
know what i [ __ ] up that and i've been
like cool
for her to have so much like hindsight
to look back on it and still think he's
just a trash one
what dang what kind of life you live in
because she's telling the story and
everybody that tells the story he paints
him
paints himself as the hero and that's
what it is i'm not gonna
i'm like people are not gonna start
telling stories about themselves it's
like okay
this is off the most people are not
gonna do most people are not gonna do
that
and that's what it is like to me it's
this
i don't ask for nothing no you expect
which makes it worse if you ask at least
there's something in the behind your
head
that there might be a yes or no you
expect it just needs to be done
you know what it's pretentious you know
i just realized that this is men's fault
yeah it is for her to be this
comfortable i've heard to say this in
hindsight means that
plenty of dudes have bought the hat
because lady dudes have symptoms that's
why i'm not that pissed
yeah and the way she looked how she
looks she got she got the thing that she
got because she looks a certain way and
everything and stuff
and yeah people are going to give her so
it's not even her fault she's been
enabled
she's fine it's also her fault but yeah
yeah yeah i see what you're saying but
you know that's why i'm not even that
pissed yeah i'm like
because it works like that in some kind
of like it works like that so
whatever it's it's yeah i think the guy
didn't take an
l well it's an l but it's not really a l
to me as i can tell like
again ladies you show up on a date and
you know you show up to do's place and
he opens the door he's about naked and
you haven't even talked about this stuff
at all
you probably would be turned off mm-hmm
you're like what the and you probably
walk away because it's so out of pocket
and random you open the door but
yeah what yeah as a man if you think l
like that
it's not a l it's so it's like if you
were
a rookie that never played basketball
in your life you were a towel boy
and then they asked you to jump on the
field because everybody's injured you go
on the field
and you lose in the finals against
lebron james
you lost against lebron james
and that's a lo that's an l but you lost
against lebron james
and that's the win the name is always
going to be there
so to me that the guy that's not a l
you you dodged one oh some different
shirts
foreign
[Music]
i am